it's an evening of fun and networking
all while benefiting help of southern
nevada we're talking about the fifth
annual night of the witches and we're
joined today by the hostess for the
night mystic mona welcome so great to
see you thank you so much this event
sounds like it's gonna be so much fun
tell us what's going on okay so this is
the best night of the witches ever it's
35
there's a costume contest you get your
first witch's brew part of it there's
raffle items including this amazing
diamond necklace oh take our house of
diamonds but you can see some of the um
you can see some of the pictures of the
people that are lined up and the people
that have done amazing things with their
hats there's a costume contest so it's
best overall
scary famous and best witch wizard so
it's for the guys too
but you can actually see how really the
people really get into the costumes as
you're seeing the pictures is just
fantastic and all proceeds benefit help
of southern nevada can you tell us a
little bit about help of southern nevada
so what they do so help is the one place
that actually helps women and children
get back on their feet so so when you've
hit hard times you can reach out to help
and help have counselors and people
available to get you going again they
also manage the shannon west homeless
youth center which is one of these
beautiful places for teenagers to find a
place to go and get training and their
high school equivalency all of that work
college everything they're just
wonderful such a great organization and
you're going to be there you're hosting
the event and
if people don't know you are psychic you
i've known you for years your gift is
truly incredible and if people do want
to
make an appointment with you for a
private reading they can do that how do
they do that yeah well there's going to
be a special offered at the event okay
you can get a little mini reading over
the phone for a donation and that'll go
they'll collect the money and they'll
just give you my name and i'll give you
get your name and i'll send a little
appointment for you but that's over the
phone
but people can reach me through my
website at mona dot vegas so
www.mona.vegas to book a session but
night of the witches has gotten so big
that we used to do readings at the event
so we're saving those for the next day
so people can actually have a little
more privacy and they're not drinking
when they actually have their that might
throw things off a little bit and you
said you would do a quick little oh yes
for you absolutely okay so with your
left hand draw me five cards and leave
them face down uh five cards
one
two
three
four
five beautiful okay okay so these don't
we don't even need those right now i'm
nervous why am i nervous okay so there's
a there's a fella around you right now
that um
i think this is a co-worker that may uh
may be leaving the station
oh boy and what's interesting about that
is that it's it may create an
opportunity for you
which um it's not doesn't even exist
right now but i'm just letting you know
and then you're kc
and then your fabulous husband
is about to also get something that he's
been waiting for right here this is him
going after something he wants because
the door flies wide open for him
and that you get to let go of the burden
of working so hard in other words you're
going to go from working hard to working
smart working effectively oh my god so
there's a shift that's about to happen
and it's something you've been waiting
for for at least seven years
wow okay so basically what i'm hearing
is that jc who is one of my co-hosts on
mercedes in the morning
he's leaving my husband something great
is happening and i'm i'm going to work
smarter now well something's about to
happen for you that comes across your
radar that you've been waiting for
and that you are aware enough to take
advantage of that opportunity it's
pretty big really eye-opening and i'm
seriously like sweating right now this
is crazy uh mr mona thank you again you
gotta check it out and look at this
beautiful necklace she's amazing she
really is i believe her night of the
witch's benefiting help of southern
nevada is happening tomorrow 6 to 8 30
p.m so you got to check it out it's
happening at grape street cafe in
downtown summerlin don't miss it it's
going to be a blast and make an
appointment with her she knows her stuff
jillian over to you why